I'm skilled baby you can catch me on a
bootleg KF podcast you feel me
my guy skill a baby for the third time
welcome back appreciate you my hey are
you gaining weight bro you looking like
you know what I'm saying you might be
hitting that [__] that grow man wait
bruh so if you listening I told you yeah
you looking like a grown-up now well the
first time I met you was in the middle
of the pandemic and you guys had like 75
guys at my studio recording and it was
just terribly responsible during covet
but you're like yeah you got the man
wait on bro you look like a grown ass
man now it's hard yeah uh hey but yo I
gotta say me and my boy s dot were just
talking about it you and the T the the
controversy tape is one of my favorite
projects of the year
y'all delivered on that [__] for sure
and I appreciate you saying that I think
you DM me and said that and I appreciate
it because I know how like you you
critical like when it comes to projects
and stuff for sure like you even said
that Drake's not up there with your
favorite projects like like you said he
ain't got like no Holy Grail like like
no you're right I did say that I pay
attention to what you say like hey man
well I'm just super proud of you man
because
you're that guy right now in Detroit
brother you're one of them guys period
appreciate you you did get snubbed on
that freshman cover I mean should have
been on there let's just say it here
crazy snub
I ain't gonna say that next year maybe
next year maybe but next year by then
it'll be too late yeah I understand them
though well they did just interview you
so you have to be nice yeah it's the
last post I just saw on your IG
yo um how are we feeling about your team
making Monty Williams the richest coach
ever
my former coach
oh no he just got fired
he did because two years in a row game
sevens the sun's got embarrassed and
eliminated yeah I'm all for it if he's
gonna help us he's going to build
culture and help the young guys yeah I
want wins though yeah yeah we need wins
like that you got Kade who's got to stay
healthy guys Ivy's a beast beast uh
what's the big dude named is it Duren
Jay Lindora and then James wiseman's on
the [__] Pistons which is random it's
random but I feel like if you get
healthy you can grab a lot of boards and
block a lot of shots Sadiq Bay got
traded to the Hawks uh I don't know who
else is on the Pistons
um I think Isaiah Stewart is a great
Steward guy oh Isaiah Stewart that's the
guy who who threw the fade with the
LeBron yeah I think he's a great glue
guy
um he's kind of like a big Pat Bev I
wanted to see who who we get with the
number I think we got number five pick I
was really I was truly rooting for the
Pistons
yeah that would have been crazy I would
have got season tickets or Sunday we got
to pick
I feel like two or three years in a row
y'all kind of like y'all you guys got
Cade but then was it last year who y'all
you guys had Ivy yeah you guys drafted
two players last year I'd be in Durham
right yeah I think I think Ivy and
Jordan and Kate with some great pickups
um I like how
um ivy can score the ball from
um every level basically and I like um I
like Jalen um during I like his
um aggression like he he 18 years old
attacking of course like Dennis Rodman
have you performed at a Pistons game yet
nope I put the Hydra I think I did the
introduction before nice
you know what I find to be [__] is
if you go to the Little Caesars Arena
they don't have five dollar Little
Caesars pizza I've heard no it's more
than that it's very disappointing
imagine you go to a game by the way it's
a piston game so the tickets are cheap
probably you're probably eat good
tonight we're about to get us a five
dollar pizza at the Little Caesars Arena
what but when you get floor seats you
can go get free pizza you do yeah free
Little Caesars Pizzas very it's like
free 7-Eleven coffee it's like yeah
thanks you know it was kind of free
anyway yeah uh anyway but no I feel like
you've been on your [__] you obviously
just dropped the deluxe to your project
that you dropped in December
um
tell me about the bidding war that you
went through before you landed
with Interscope oh it was a crazy being
where before I got within the scope
guessing uh
I had so many people I had people trying
to back door people I ain't even know
like like you know you know you don't
know your worth like with when it comes
to like music until you get like into
music business right and then it just
helped me know my worth it was just a
crazy being where it went from one
number to another number with
um what certain circumstances then they
they get took out of like the contracts
and all that they changed so yeah it's
almost like your leverage was going up
probably in the middle of all that in
the middle of it like hey we might have
talked a month ago but the shit's gotta
look you gotta take this out you gotta
take this out like like I I had talked
to gaffing it
um they was like I was damn near signed
right and then the lawyer had didn't
send a contract like kept playing on
sitting in the contract and they are
almost out with somebody else who'd you
almost signed with oh man where did you
find it I forgot where did I find it but
he was he signed young boy forgot what
he was at Columbia he went somewhere
else
um but I almost signed with a couple of
people Capital was on me Atlantic was on
me anyway yeah United master or
something United Masters I heard it is
uh drop they got a big X the plug right
now yeah they had tried there I have a
lot of people any rapper trailers on you
like like I feel like CMG is like the
type of thing where Yo Gotti would just
bring you like a like 500 000 in cash
and be like here you go yeah but you
know it's it's all type of politics that
go in today right right right because
yeah yeah yeah I forgot who else is yeah
I for sure speaking of I was surprised
to see it was very dope to see you and T
get together but obviously him inside I
have like an interesting history not
necessarily like super crazy but
you and Sana came up I mean I've met you
through Sada baby was that like a an
easy project to make happen separate of
like it was an easy project to make
happen because I don't put my business
in personal stuff together and plus
um I don't I don't get into people that
already know each other business like I
don't do that I don't like I think
um I don't even think the world should
know that business because it's just
it's personal for sure
um I try to separate personal feelings
when I do business but
um T ain't doing nothing to me I I'm
actually cool as hell with teeth right
now like we're cool as hell he's a great
dude he's a great dude like I [__] with
him has he uh invited you to his Grand
Theft Auto server yeah he just he really
just got my [__] built he so are you
online like playing games I just got it
Bill he um he sent somebody to my house
and he sent me like oh so you have like
a gaming rig yeah he built me like a six
thousand dollar PC or something oh [__]
yeah I just got built right before I got
to Cali like three days ago so so you're
about to be you're about to be a GTA
acting I'm Charles Jones the mechanic so
in GTA you already have your character
Charles Jones The Mechanic and you can't
break character while on the mic no I'm
Charles Jones the mechanic and if you
need Strikers I ain't saying I got him
but I ain't saying I don't got him I
love it for people who don't know what's
happening there is this role-playing
online pocket of Grand Theft Auto and if
you're in it you gotta play the
character yeah I ain't saying I got
Strikers but I ain't saying I don't got
Striker's life what is a striker I mean
the the things the Sticks no no Strikers
I don't know what a striker is I don't
play [__] fast cars oh okay okay so
you are the guy you're The Chop Shop guy
now I'm the mechanic but I got Strikers
okay if y'all need Strikers call Charles
Jones in the game CJ CJ in the game what
happens if you break character do you
get killed I think you could put out the
server but I'll never break character so
I won't know wow I feel like that
inadvertently you being Charles Jones on
a GTA server is going to help your
acting career shortly for sure because
you're going to be in movies for sure
I'm calling it now have you ever like
are do you have those aspirations yeah
I'm in a Toby movie that just came up of
course you are
fire
I was the lead role bro I just go on
Twitter every month or so and I'll just
type in 2B and hit videos and just see
the clips so you're you're the lead
actor in The 2B movie yeah what's it
called outside
are you outside in it yeah I'm outside
yeah how what's the can it give me a
synopsis of what what the plot is
especially
um talk about how kids jump in gangs and
be in the streets and um I'm I'm going
to school I get kicked out of school a
lot
um and the girl why don't you pull up
the trailer real quick yeah one of the
girls in the movie died and it was
supposed to happen like we posted gave
her a fake perk or something but
it just causes us to have so many Ops
people's online talking about it all
types of people getting shot on live
Instagram live basically everything is
going on
I can't find each other
did you watch uh
did you watch the skillet baby uh short
or the uh T Grizzly short films for his
last album no I didn't all right
actually really good I gotta go watch it
now not a bad actor
very very like uh that whole project was
just like straight up like a visual like
if you if you ain't watching the [__]
movies you're probably not might not get
it I ain't gonna lie um and I told this
to T I feel like this year like other
than him coming out when he just blew up
crazy big I feel like he been rapping
like the best ever like I feel like he
just I've been in studio with him he's
been gone he like he'd be making me be
like damn what the
like you feel I was gonna say what is is
it a is it uh is it something where you
guys are cutting some of these records
and obviously you get inspired to go
harder but is there also any sort of
like friendly competition no it's a
friendly competition like I want to get
at them like we had never say it but
it's like he'd say something so crazy
that I've like the whole room would be
like man you better go and then I'll say
something he'll be like man I got like T
when I first met him he was just like he
got to do this one thing like they only
talk about Lil Wayne and Jay-Z doing
like where he just go to the mic and
just do a 16 off just off the top of his
head
and it'd be like the craziest stuff I I
didn't heard and stuff but then he like
man sometimes I gotta write because
you'll be saying some crazy stuff so
it's really cool obviously there's
something about what's in the water in
Detroit right now between yourself we
talked about cash kid baby Tron just
these like great one-liners that you're
just like oh [__] or it's like
especially with the sports bars and [__]
like there's something about the sports
bars that you have that cash kids got
that baby trans guy were just like Jesus
they kind of gotta know to know like
random NBA references and [__] like
what's your favorite
bar you have in your phone right now
that you've written recently give me a
line give me a one line that you just
you just wrote recently you're like oh
when people hear this
uh
my my new way I kill people I let them
live
oh
yeah I said I found a new way to kill
people I just let them live that's deep
I look forward to uh what I don't look
forward to it but you know it's coming
there's gonna be so many people making
these Titanic submarine bars in the next
like two weeks
I don't wanna I don't want to make fun
of the people down no they died I feel
like it's [__] up what's happening
because it's like a lot of people lost
their life and it's become like a joke
online I think um
there's no sense around people in the
world no more and that's a big deal like
that I think that's a big deal to me
like people making fun of people dying
and stuff that's not like when you do it
in your own household or something it's
cool like why put that into the world
for the world to consume why add to that
people like laughing at negative stuff
like going online and trying to say the
most negative stuff possible is not
funny to me how do you try to disconnect
from like reading comments or like
paying too much attention to some of the
online [__] because I used to not read
them like I used to not read them and
not just because it's negative it's just
be like I don't want to get caught up
and I know Fame is a drug like when you
hire you hide when you love you low but
I read them not and I laugh at them I do
all because I I I know myself I'm strong
enough not to care I don't care
you don't think subconsciously it might
somehow like be up there not because I
um I know how to decipher
um fact from fiction so it'd be like if
you say this I know this ain't true and
if you say this I know it is true so you
do got the right to say that because
it's true and then it just be like I use
a lot of it for motivation or like
um I like I'm I'm my biggest critic so
I'll just be wanting to see what people
do and don't like about me so do you
feel like because I feel like you've
improved immensely over the last few
years just as an artist as a rapper
um
do you ever go back and listen to like
stuff or hear stuff that's like maybe a
few years old and be like damn I was
like I'm so much better now like I swear
I listen to a lot of stuff and my voice
be like like you like you say I got
bigger and stuff and then my voice used
to crack and I used to be like sounding
like a real little kid so yeah I was
listening somebody was telling me a song
that I made a few years ago and I was
telling them like man I sound like a kid
it was trash for sure I do that all the
time how uh important is it for you to
keep like pushing yourself as a as a as
an emcee because you care about I feel
like you you're a high level rapper you
know what I'm saying I talked to Chris
Brown one time like a couple weeks ago I
was at his rehearsal with tea and I
asked him like how do you stay grounded
and he told me I act like I didn't
accomplish nothing so I think that's Mo
that's the most important you act like
you just like my coaches to tell me when
I get in the end zone act like I've been
there before so I just act like I don't
do nothing that's the biggest thing that
a lot of somebody didn't told me in a
while Chris Brown told me that I act
like he act like he don't haven't
accomplished anything because if you let
uh if you let your recent [__] get to
your head you're gonna get lazy get lazy
yeah get complacent complacency is the
worst [__] ever man yeah Chris that's a
nice just hanging with Chris Brown see a
fan I don't think he's a fan not yet he
remembered me from when I met him with
Sada a few years ago that's one of the
most humblest people I met
um from my experience she was my top two
celebrities I ever met was G herbo and
Chris Brown for real yeah
what was that like it was cool as hell
like we also like the nicest guy ever
swear to God the most humble cool
[__] alive like he he recorded a
lot of his album from like a couple
years ago in the mild Studio that you
recorded at
I just met him a few months ago like he
like he just wanted the nicest humblest
people like you said and he's like one
of the most like emotionally wise
artists I've ever met like he's very
self-aware he's aware of like what he
says how it could affect [__] and like
super man I love I love G for sure he's
a great guy
um
what's coming I mean obviously the
deluxe just dropped but I I you already
know you got to have another album in
the pipeline yeah I'm trying to drop an
album um in August or September
um I'm just working on making a meal I
want this when I do this album I want it
to be like the best music I ever put out
like I got a few records that I know
gonna go and then I'm just working a
field against a record slot I know like
on a mixtape it could be like some
people might not like this some people
might like this everybody like this I
want every song to be at like that it's
non-stop no skips gotta have no skips
for sure you uh you and Greedo work
together drop the video together uh he
just left here shout out to Greedo but
uh
give me your like I you know I do think
there's this correlation between
the west coast and Detroit for whatever
reason specifically the bankritos from
LA but I think like the bay obviously
Draco Greedo those guys have always been
so heavily tapped in with Detroit what
do you think it is about the two
sections that are very like offensive
forever Detroit uh people like from
Detroit been coming to Cali and just
tapping in even though we don't if we
like we ain't had no big artists and
stuff like that but we've been when when
you do something you move west a lot of
people move west and um they say that
they like our cousins a lot of them
artists come to Detroit like so it'd
just be like I just feel like we got a
lot of stuff in common and stuff right
except for the gang bang stuff right but
Detroit is taking a lot of gangbang
culture and running with it though
its own politics there for sure yeah do
you feel like Detroit as a city has
calmed down in that aspect in that way
at least on I feel like it's in terms of
artists working together it feels a lot
more people work together now people do
work together but no it ain't calm down
on like see artists see artists in the
streets it's a whole different for sure
but I feel like even like five six years
ago I just weren't really moving
together like that yeah but I think a
lot of um where I'm from a lot of people
try to still be caught up in the streets
and and still had his gangster image and
stuff like that when they don't have to
I always say like even though I got
stuff going on I'd never be a mad rapper
why would I be mad and I'm making all
this money and how to change my life
change a lot of people's lives around me
why is everybody still mad there's no
point has any of the like super OG's uh
from like kind of the whole era before
you and two errors probably before you
whether it's like Royce Big Sean M have
they tapped in with what you're doing I
mean I just Big Sean just made my mom a
day last night he just shout out to Big
Sean he made my mom a day talking to my
mama Big Sean was humble when I met him
too when I he
um I I'll ask him can I call my mama on
the phone and he talked to her on the
phone oh [__] you talked to my mom oh so
you're in the studio with Sean last
night oh [__] you talked to my mama on
the phone
that's fire
he made my day like he just made my mama
that was like a humbling experience like
that that just was crazy like I was just
so happy he don't even know how happy he
just made me he made my day like a kid
at a candy store your mom's just like
did she expect it when you FaceTiming no
she just answered I I um facetimed when
I was with Chris Brown too he made my my
sister's day like they just they don't
even know they think like I'm just a
rapper and I'm really fanned out I just
don't act like it but I'll be fanned out
see what Sean did you work on any music
last night no but we um we're gonna get
together probably this weekend doing
something that'd be crazy what about
Eminem I haven't I've never seen Eminem
I do want to do some music with Eminem
that'd be fine like I never seen Eminem
but I know he's big for our culture like
everything that he did
um and I think
um the disconnect between Eminem and a
lot of artists from Detroit now is that
he's not a street guy you feel me yeah
he's I mean he's the most successful
rapper ever ever he's disconnected from
the street because he's not in the
streets yeah I mean he's a yeah for sure
and he doesn't owe anybody anything like
I feel like during his era he did a lot
to try to help what was happening now
I'm not sure it's his job when it comes
to like that trick trick Royce and
Autumn right that was his error he
helped his area records with trick trick
Royce I mean the D12 guys uh I'm trying
to think if there's any
I mean then there was that whole other
side of Detroit that's like Village and
Jay Dilla and that's like saying Lil
Wayne got to go to New Orleans and work
where every artist comes from the world
hey that is kind of true because I feel
like the Detroit artists be giving
Eminem hell sometimes they do and they
and artists in New Orleans ain't giving
way in hell because he you know that's
yeah I mean look Eminem is one of the
greatest of all time I mean everybody
want to be successful so bad but you
gotta understand that Eminem wouldn't
even sound right on a lot of songs from
Detroit if you just if you yeah if you
put Eminem on some of these records it
probably sound it'd suck
I'm just being real because M&M we a lot
of people don't have real lyrical
content from Detroit we more of a A vibe
right and I feel like a lot of people
um the flow wouldn't even match like
when it comes to putting together
records I've been especially like the
BPM level I'm like I don't know how
Eminem would sound on like a Detroit
beat like I don't like I just don't know
if I want to I don't know I don't think
anybody wants to hear that respectfully
what's up y'all we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good friends at my bookie that's
right it is NBA Finals you gotta Hammer
the Nuggets I don't know they might
sweep the the heat I would look at the
like serious odds on that go to my
bookie right now let's get some money
man all right baseball of course is in
full effect we got Stanley Cup finals
NFL seasons on the way sign up at
mybookie.ag right now use the promo code
bootleg and you will get that first
deposit bonus
all right look I don't care where you're
at you can go to mybookie.ag Let's
gamble on some sports they got the
casino you can do live Blackjack you can
do live roulette craps you could do all
kinds of slots and of course bet on the
NBA Finals bet on the NHL uh Stanley Cup
finals crazy shots of the Vegas golden
knights that's what I'm rooting for and
of course baseball season man all right
so look right now mybookie.ag use that
promo code bootleg uh and sign up when
you do use uh that promo code they're
going to give you a first deposit bonus
straight to your account free money all
right mybookie.ag go do that also gotta
give a shout out to our family at Blue
chew that's right ladies and gentlemen
it's getting hot outside that means
I don't know what that means it's just
hot so I feel like when it's hot people
want to [__] more right so you know
fellas if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it happens to the best of us
I'm sure maybe you are old maybe you are
dealing with stress at work maybe you
don't want to sleep with the same lady
that you're married to over and over
need a little extra motivation to get
that thing stayed up you know what I
mean go to uh bootoo.com use the promo
code bootleg and they'll send it
straight to your door three-month supply
of Bluetooth for free all right now
there's Bluetooth work yes it does
you're gonna get a free month supply to
be able to see for yourself boucher.com
promo code bootleg uh now if you don't
know what it is it is the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form and you do not have to go
to a doctor's appointment all right you
do everything online you don't have to
go sit at a doctor's office and talk to
some old man in a lab coat about your
dick issues not necessary anymore in
2023 all right so go to Bluetooth sign
up with that promo code bootleg get a
month supply for free let's get back to
the interviews yeah yeah so I don't
think nobody wants to hear that at all
for real you guys working together to be
crazy maybe you go do some [__] like
you'd be like yo I I went in on this end
this is I did this with you in mind no I
had to sit there and and write for like
a week yeah and then
um get my flow right and be like em I
got this for you like I asked Big Sean
that last night like did he ever
um go into it like I'm about to chew
these guys up but he like
the records he been on like his biggest
records with people he did a song left
for open verse and he didn't know who
was getting on it and then so if they
end up going in that's he's not gonna go
back and change his [__] because that's
kind of against rapper rules you know
yeah for sure so
I have to prepare for that though that's
still him are you currently are you
writing stuff down when you have an idea
are you just straight punching in like
what are you I'm doing both yeah I gotta
be for me to write to it I gotta
extremely love to be like like you gotta
have to be the head inside but if you're
driving around you think of a bar you're
gonna make a note of it for sure yeah
for sure because a lot some bars you
just can't you can't waste them you
can't forget him you can't forget that
for sure J Cole current
minority owner of the Hornets I'm sure
you've seen do you have any aspirations
to one day be a minority owner for sure
yeah heck yeah
what first thing make the pizzas five
dollars not a free pizza free pizza when
you come in the arena well if you go to
Little Caesars and you're not getting
the extra mostess like the extra cheese
extra pepperoni it's for the extra Buck
you're [__] up by the way now that
you're like traveling the country
can we have an honest conversation about
yeah
the food in Detroit
is better than everywhere in the country
I mean that's a bold-faced lie where you
think you think Cali got better food oh
sure
I think listen I love Detroit when I was
there but I went to like four different
Coney spots bro that's that's why who
sent you the colony
people in Detroit only eat cognacy D's
on eight mile by truth terrible place
you were supposed to go to Zorba's I
went to the one I went to the one in
that that Sada took me to which is his
spot that might have been that it's like
in the red zone or wherever on the east
side no you're supposed to go to zorbas
on the east side if you're on the west
side you're supposed to go to L George's
but that's just counties people only eat
Coney at two o'clock in the morning we
did have
a fake I wouldn't say fake
uh baby Tron took us to a place that was
kind of like Raising Cane's you ain't go
to the Burger trip
and the best thing I ate though was a
burger that Juan got me you ain't go to
the Burger trip Burger truck did you go
to Sweetwater no Burger truck I went to
the pancake place though the breakfast
spot everyone talks about that [__] was
gas did you go to Mason's no
Midwest Grill did you go to somebody
auntie in the backyard on the grill
you messing up bro you got have you been
to a taco truck in L.A
yes
and got me some uh horchata they gotta
get the [__] pot store bro they gotta
shave the meat off of the thing onto the
tank you think that's better than
everything in Detroit of course no you
gotta go through Detroit with me also
best food I had outside of the burger
one got me was definitely the food court
Asian food at MGM Grand
you got to go through Detroit with me
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna show you how
to eat in Detroit okay all right do you
guys ever go over to Canada
I'm Phil oh so you can't Canon is a wrap
for for you for a minute Drake puts the
call in yeah at least for like five
years Drake reached out to you no but I
met Drake twice how was that I I that
was crazy I was at a private party one
time in New York and I just looked up
and Drake was reaching for my hand
because somebody they had no Drake is on
my label and they was like this is I'm
like damn this Drake he just walk around
here just like he normal for sure for
sure he walk around here like ignore him
within the second time was at his
private party for Super Bowl at at
um Dave and Buster's oh yeah he has
those
that was Drake is an interesting guy was
that in Arizona yeah yeah in Chandler or
in uh yeah yeah in uh I know where it
was in the the Dave and Busters
outside
it's the outside mall in AZ
he's so hard for that I ain't gonna lie
what was it like was this your first
Super Bowl
as like popping popping where you're
like not like hanging out with Sada like
you're like skill a baby yeah little
baby brought me out
at that ratchet ass party yeah on the
west side at the [__] Stratus Event
Center yeah yes brought me out yeah that
was hard there was a I don't even want
to talk about but a lot of yo Super Bowl
man [__] be scamming are these
promoters oh my god oh they said he was
going everywhere oh my God I'm glad our
club is like we are the only club that
everything happened how it's supposed to
happen
he packed it out though no for sure it
was like there was like a future day
party that was supposed to happen
earlier in the day in that same spot
[__] went left he didn't show up it was
bad instead Dre and Michelle showed up
imagine paying to see future performance
Andreas there you're like well at least
we got Draya guys Andrea performing 56
nights that have been a [__]
that had been a hell of a Netflix show
oh my God like hey guys we got Drea but
she's gonna do your favorite future hits
go ahead go ahead
oh that'd be great
that sounds like an amazing time I
actually might have been more happy to
see that me because I'm a dick you know
I've been like this is great I kind of
try to Pat myself like like all my toxic
ways after the future
he's a toxic guy yeah I'll try to be
toxic as him in life what's your highest
toxic trait you've uh learned from
Futures influence I tell people to call
me and then I don't answer the phone
like you'll tell them like yo hit me
call me like I get a girl number like
tell her to call him and give her my
number and I won't answer
like I don't I didn't get some [__] like
this like
I didn't like been [__] with a girl
like I like I be like him I like my girl
so like I love him like damn they're all
of them and how many are there
is one at the moment
and then one
all of the ones who are watching are
gonna be like I'm the one the one they
you're the one it's her though she know
who she is she knows like but my toxic
thing I did like I like be messing with
a girl go by or something like I go buy
somebody something today and then we'll
never answer for the rest of my life
she'll buy somebody something and then
cut them off yeah I like that at least I
gave you a I gave you a uh departing
gift yeah right like here's a lot of
girls think when they meet me that we
about to do it or something you don't
have kids right no thank God right you
gotta just hold off for a while
because once you have that kid kind of
throws a whole wrench into your game
bruh yeah
a lot of girls think we're gonna have
sexual relations but we're not
I just I'm here for a good time
are you the kind of guy that
wants to know you can [__] and then
that's enough exactly
um
I think that's damn near it's like about
the chase and then once you know it's
like I don't even
I know I could do it now so what's the
point because one day one day I might
want to do it
um
I like that
shout out to you it's like a high you
still haven't tried a honey pack like me
inside I was telling you about no I
don't do drugs it's not a drug it's a
drug it's from the performance enhancer
it is a ped it is a PD for sure some
Barry Bond [__]
but it's almost like
if you let's say you're you're Skillet
baby right you're gonna start probably
smashing famous women soon you're a good
looking kid no I'm married
okay well one day if you're not married
and the opportunity comes for you to
sleep with
a famous woman who maybe you've loved
them
who's single
sweetie's not single I don't like single
women okay sweetie
you might want to do the ped
you might want to hit the bluetooth.com
forward slash bootleg and get a free
month supply same active ingredients
vibrant see how let's go to
bluetooth.com you might want to take a
blue tube because then you're just you
know you want to be
it's like if steroids were legal right
and you got drafted to the MLB I look
like on these steroids no but if you got
drafted to baseball
and it was like 98.99 you would be crazy
not to do steroids you're in the major
leagues you're with sweetie she's the
major leagues you might as well hit that
corner store get that honey pack get
that [__] cracking bruh no she's gonna
like me too much I just told you I'm
toxic I don't want people to like me
when people start liking you do you not
like that yeah damn
that is toxic as [__] I think females
like you more when y'all like them and
you're like I think you're right you
like them or when they don't like you
so that kind of equals a lot of
unhealthy uh toxic toxic interactions
with women damn do you find that Detroit
women are different from women in other
cities they sure visit for sure Detroit
women
like
and other cities that cater to to us
like in other cities where I go like
they that's their culture like uh
they damn nearly die for you do you
trade with me yeah they have something
on the
dance yeah they're crazy I don't want to
talk about Detroit women I love them
like I love women are women at home hey
we got some of the most beautiful people
ever but they [__]
there's that in what way though I had a
lady drive through my garage
without the door being open
drove through it so she ran through your
house yeah
what kind of car was it how much damage
are we talking my garage was damaged car
was like front end damage
I didn't have some [__] what did you do
to her to make her behave in that manner
I loved her
the right way
and she obviously loved you back enough
to be angry enough to commit a felony he
knows that was love though what do you
think that is
lust obsession
to you're I mean if you gotta if you get
mad enough for you say I'm going to
drive my vehicle into this person's
house and risk my freedom [__] up my car
[__] up their house
they gotta love you I'll be having some
toxic stuff going on is that the
craziest thing a female's done to you no
but I don't want to talk about the other
crazy stuff the girls and dear to me
well when you got shot it wasn't a girl
that shot you right no okay I got a baby
double check you know I don't know who
shot me still don't know no
was it like wrong time wrong place type
[__] or do you think they were looking
for you I don't think nobody was looking
for me I could say you strike me as the
most like mellow like mannered dude when
that happened it was scary for sure yeah
but best bullet that ever happened to me
only bullet right yeah
and let's keep it the best bullet though
why I got richer it helped out I think
so I would like to think so
I mean with 50 Cent got shot nine times
it kind of yeah people were like yo 50
you heard about 50 years nine times this
guy's I think I like to consider that
but I wish I had it like the bullet I
was like I could just put it in the
trophy case or something that's fire
that's a million dollar bullet yo so you
used to play football in high school
yeah I played JV at high school though
what uh where were you wide receiver no
I was a quarterback oh you were a
quarterback oh [__] who'd you model your
game after Mike V
so you could run yeah I ain't fast
though not fast no like Mike Vegas did
you model uh your pet owning after Mike
Vick as well my pet owning no wow I
think Mike Vick was the best pet owner
though
was he yeah I think all those
allegations aren't true
I mean that's a take yeah I think that
wasn't true
so are we saying that we don't think
Mike Vick fought dogs yeah I don't think
so I think Mike Vick was the best like
model athlete ever oh he's great and I
loved his second win when he got out and
he went with the [__] Eagles that
first year back oh whoever said Mike
Vick fought dogs and he wasn't that
wasn't there was lying whoever said Mike
Vick fought dogs obviously didn't play
with him in Madden yeah because that guy
is unbeatable man like oh five oh six oh
my God when he was on the cover in the
Falcons jersey
oh you just pick the Falcons all you got
to do was this get to the goal line
right
snapped the ball run to the opposite end
of the field go all the way to the right
and then run back up to the left
and run down the field the longest
random play ever
[__] gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our family at Odd Socks that's
right the most comfortable socks in the
world ladies and gentlemen uh go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg cab or bootleg both promo codes
work you'll save 20 out at checkout uh
20 off these are the Odd Socks Basics
all right now you can get like a pack of
all black pack of all whites of course
they got all kind of crazy licenses WWE
Cheech and Chong they got Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles they got SpongeBob
SquarePants bruh look they got the
SpongeBob SquarePants Krabby Patty
draws
yeah
yeah now you don't want crabs but you do
want Mr crab's underwear because these
are fire all right so look go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code uh bootleg save 20 off a
checkout and uh yeah listen trust me
when I say most comfortable socks you'll
ever put on your [__] feet
and the most comfortable boxer briefs
what are we talking about man all right
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off for checkout great gift and
and just treat yourself all right also
got a shout out to our family a King
Palm now if you guys don't know about
King pong kingpong is all natural baby
yes all right we're talking about the
leader when it comes to uh tobacco-free
natural organic Leaf wraps if you're a
smoker a toad or a straight west coaster
you know what I'm saying whatever you're
into King Palms they got it for you
what's great about
um these these are like one of the best
uh products that they sell now this is a
terpene infused tobacco-free leaf
and what's dope is you stuff your flour
into it and then you press on the thingy
you know what I'm saying and then you
got flavor I'm going to show you what it
looks like when it's stuffed
with some great tree from Jardin of
course
ah look at that
right get that thing stuffed up
the tip has got that flavor in it uh
wherever you're at man make sure you
check out the uh
um you know they got the smoke shops
they got those on lock they got
7-Elevens on lock we only smoking out of
King Palms baby you already know what it
is and if you go to
kingpoms.com
kingpom.com kingpom.com
and you use the promo code bootleg Kev
you will save 50 off at checkout half
off at checkout 50 off if you go to
kingpom.com and use that promo code the
promo code is down below go run it up
try some of these flavors too man the
peach pineapple the Strawberry Shortcake
they just got so much going on there's
also all kind of dope smoking
accessories you can get half off y'all
what are we talking about save 50 off
kingpom.com promo code below it's either
bootleg or bootleg have them these promo
codes got my head hurt try both of them
all right one of them get you 50 off God
damn it anyway let's get back to the
interview
um all right so you're gonna drop an
album August September do any ideas
gonna be on the new [__] who's gonna be
on there yeah I don't like features yeah
I got I'm I'm hoping Dirk sent me um my
verse back uh Polo G
um Jeremiah I got a record with Jeremiah
radio join maybe
[Music]
um
um hopefully I get back in there with g
herbo
um
a couple people that it just in the
works and I hope I get to hopefully I
get a lot of on this one song and then
oh Lotto yeah and Kodak Kodak would be
fire anybody from the West Coast
um
I don't really work with a lot of West
Coast artists and that's what I'm trying
to tap into now I got a record with um
Greedo but he wanted for his next um
tape so I'm gonna get let them get that
um what about your label what's going on
with your label like far as what as far
as what roster sign a new artist oh in
my label we eat the most I'm trying to
um get this West Coast girl Savvy she
heard
um
and yeah that's your logo right with the
tent and uh yeah it's a great logo and
and dollar dollar and flare I wonder if
your logo is a tent and a tree do you
actually camp like a skillet baby a
Savvy camper no no
I don't like bears
nobody does
have you considered getting into camping
because it is the logo to your label
no but I would probably be this the
closest I'm gonna get to Camping is when
I go on tour and I put the big tent on
the stage you should go camping you
should go with a bunch of have you done
mushrooms no I don't do drugs I I mean
I'm aware but you haven't never done
shrooms no you could always start I'm
scared of them you should be
so how would I do
hey man you'd be having [__] drive to
your house bruh you'd be living a lot
more riskier than doing shrooms
no because I know at the end of the day
they gonna hurt my house but not me
you don't know that no I noticed
well I didn't I had somebody trash my
whole house pick up knives hit me with
candles and [__] but were they lit no
hit me with candles but you know candles
the outside of Canada they're very hard
for sure so the artist and then
eventually when I just sat down on the
couch and said man all right man I'm on
probation you're gonna get me in trouble
I'm gonna just let you do this
it stopped the man is just that you
entertain the [__] with Detroit
females they gonna keep going I think
you gotta uh
you got to be careful man you gotta be
[__] with some toxic women bruh it's
Detroit these women are assaulting you
physically I call them good coochie
monsters good Gucci man there is
something about the women with the best
cool cool
usually are psychopaths
usually they got daddy issues for sure
for sure for sure yeah she did that yeah
I know she did if she [__] drove a
car through your house for sure
I wanted you over that what the hell
called the police I mean I'd assume if
someone drove a car through the front of
my house my neighbors are calling the
cops [__] what I'm doing I ain't calling
a cop I called the police and told her
to leave I said when I called the police
I said somebody broke into my house man
it's really crazy they broke into my
house with a whole car didn't take
nothing there is man they broke it into
my house while I was gone man in this
[__] it was crazy were you renting or
buying this house I was renting that's
why I had to I had to I had to call the
police police
I was really at a condo and I was going
the condo was going to put me out if I
didn't have like rightfully so yeah if I
didn't have like proof of uh the police
I'm evicting you bro yeah they was gonna
kick me out like how many times my rent
went from
2500 to 3500. 3 500 in Detroit sounds
like he lived in a castle
I kind of have a big house
yeah
Detroit is very cheap it is compared to
La yeah
do you own any real estate yet
um I own a couple Hood homes
what's the hood home like the ones that
like fix our uppers have you started
fixing them up no
in Detroit in Detroit they there is a
high level of breaking into homes that
are abandoned taking all the copper out
right taking all the pipes out and then
selling them quiet and doing all this
but then selling all the copper right
Danny Brown had a song called scrap or
die
and it was all about
breaking in the houses taking a cover
yeah have you dealt with that with the
houses you bought have you been like
cared to look to see if there's copper
left no I hope they do I hope they do
something so yeah do something man we're
just gonna say that I'll take whoops so
I could win
and make some money okay
well listen man uh the deluxe of the
album is out controversy with uh T
Grizzlies out
new album coming soon
uh new videos off the deluxe on the way
a little Tyler video
baby trying video and Rallo Rodriguez
video
shout out to rylo shelter big baby
tron's [__] great man I loved his uh
the new lyrical lemonade should he
dropper he's just like that song 100
yeah he's just like 100 different
outfits
that was hard fight and then you know do
you know baby tron's dad used to be
signed a psychopath records yeah
were you hip to that wave no ICP I
talked to um twisted uh no I talked to
um baby trying about it he's like my dad
was a big rapper and I'm like for real
that was crazy so you're not aware of
Juggalos no that's what he did say to
Juggalos I think that's what he said wow
Juggalos are like uh
well at a certain point in time they
were considered a gang by the FBI
a national gang the Juggalos was them
like the barbershop rappers
oh no the barbershop quartet
so ICP are two white dudes who dress
like clowns
that's what he said his I think baby
tron's dad wore face paint that's what
he said he said his daddy's dressed up
like clown I ain't want to say it
wouldn't be wrong but that's what he
said listen these guys
are independent Pioneers for sure they
had beef with Eminem
but their fans are the absolute most
ridiculous this is these guys right here
why did they fans have beef with Eminem
I mean why did they have beef which one
is Baby John is that uh I don't know
[__] baby tron's dad is he was signed to
them no so the Juggalos they all have
like these hatchet man tattoos
and like now they're like 40 and like
teaching like fourth grade
um you notice for a fact I mean there's
definitely like so you've never seen a
white guy at a gas station with one of
these tattoos like on his calf muscle
well really I ain't really see white
guys at a gas station growing up that's
fair
well you're about to tour the country
right you might see the hatchet man
tattoo that's a juggalo but see now that
like you know the Juggalo things kind of
I don't want to say it's over because
it's definitely a for Life thing right
now these guys had to get real jobs it
was Juggalo and Gigolo the same thing
unfortunately for them no
there's a a juggalo is
listen it's the name of ICP fan you know
what Beyonce has the beehive
Nikki's got the barbs they got the
Juggalos
were you a juggalo
[__] no that's it so no I wasn't so
that's ICP so oh it was an Eminem fan no
actually I mean yeah I'm I am I mean
growing up I was wondering Like Hell
cast and like Nas and mutang and [__]
but I loved Eminem
but Eminem yeah I loved Eminem but I
wasn't like [__] super like
you know like I loved Eminem but you
know I wasn't like one of them folks you
want Marshall Mathers yeah wait let's
see uh baby John's dad
um now I'm curious baby Tron dad
it was
the [__] was his name
I don't even know it doesn't even say
but yeah he was signed a psychopath
right that's crazy bro you got to tap in
they do the Gathering of the Juggalos
every year it's like a festival in the
middle of nowhere baby Tylenol don't go
he might one day
the Gathering of the Juggalos on private
property in the middle of Ohio
and it's a bunch of Juggalos they all
meet up it's like a music festival so
hello rappers comedians there's a
wrestling ring there's wrestling
happening they have a drug Bridge we
need to protect baby China at all of
course I agree you're like the biggest
rapper we got right now we got to take
baby Tron to the Gathering of the
Juggalos make everything full circle
you're about to piss on yourself
wow
okay
you pissed right before the interview
how much [__] water are you drinking
over there well because of our producer
having to piss on himself
we're gonna wrap up the interview with
Skillet hey man Gathering of the
Juggalos let's go together we'll paint
our faces
nobody will know a test I just paint I
just wear um ski masks to little Tyler's
concert though and people know it was me
I ain't like that damn
tucked my chains and everything
I think the days of the push iced tea
masks are dying certain places are
Banning them I think in Atlanta you
can't wear them into any like you can't
even wear them without people knowing
who you are How You Gonna rob somebody
it's the old-fashioned way
oh put your hands up
if you tell anybody that it's me I'll
kill you that's the way you do it now
but you don't want to do that because
that's against the lawn it's not it's
not you know you're you're better person
where did you rob somebody
I definitely have stolen before
I know I jacked the whole chick's DVD
collection when I was like 14. it was
porn no there was this girl that we met
on the internet we called it the slob
monster
so listen so back in the day before you
were probably alive how old are you 24.
okay so I'm 36 so you were alive you
were like two
so there used to be these chat rooms
like MSN chat rooms right so you'd go
and you'd find [__] on these chat
rooms so me and my best friend Ramses
who is older than me 16 he had his
license I was 14 didn't have my license
we met this [__] online right and she
was like 14 or 15. and uh she was like
I'll suck y'all off pull up right so we
pull up and this [__] catfished us
right because she sent us pictures of
somebody who wasn't her man it's this
[__] chunky ass [__] nerdy ass
pasty white [__] with glasses
and I'm like hell no but my boy Ramses
is with the shits he's like nah bro she
about to service long story shirt short
this chick ends up sucking off my friend
group once every two weeks for like a
year
one day Ramses picks me up he's like
we're going to the slob monsters house
right her parents aren't there so we go
over to this we call her the slob
monster we go over to the slop Monster's
crib my boy Ramses is getting domed up
in her bedroom and her parents got a
sick ass DVD collection right this is
when you had that whole DVD collection
on display I took every one of those
discs out of the case
and [__] just kept taking them
outside of the trunk bro I had I had a
CD book of [__] this whole I probably
had 300 DVDs off this bitch's house I
ain't gonna lie my crazy catfish moment
I was like nah
yeah nine getting catfished that sounds
like was it by a man or a woman hell no
I was that was when everybody was on the
uh remember they had the hotlines like
the phone of course and you could talk
to people in fact I'm talking to
somebody on there trying to be freaky
and [__] they sent me a picture and [__]
I'm thinking it's them so [__] I
keep talking to them and then my mama
check my phone I ask her why I keep
being on the phone and [__] I'm like no
my sister checked my phone and she like
you dumb as hell you thought cause of my
feelings got hurt right she like you
thought this was about to she was gonna
pull up on you this Nicki Minaj
and I ain't know it was Nicki Minaj
oh man that's how we end the interview
you got catfished by a [__] just take
your picture Nicki Minaj when you were
nine years old
shout out to you all right buddy hey
stay safe with these female Skillet baby
I appreciate you brother appreciate you
boom hey appreciate y'all watching
another interview brought to you by our
good Folks at hardean now listen y'all
when you're in Las Vegas you get in that
[__] Uber you land at the airport hit
that taxi tell him to take you to hard
Dean the number one premium cannabis
dispensary in the [__] world y'all
I'm telling you you walk in they treat
you like a king or a queen or whatever
you're into all right they got the
craziest selection to premium cannabis
you'll see period anywhere let alone in
Las Vegas but just anywhere all right
not only can you go get the best tree
you will get the best experience the
best customer service the best bud
tenders you walk in the hard Dean and
that [__] just smells amazing they got
their own [__] scent literally you
get into my car I got a bottle of it my
car smells like Harding because it's
just the best [__] place
um go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to their
website
hardinglasvegas.com all right when you
go you're in Vegas you'll pull up tell
them I sent you they're going to take
care of you the right way all right look
they got these things in there man these
Moon Rock uh pre-rolls that I just had
that just absolutely melted my face off
shout out to hardine all right you gotta
go [__] with hard Dean man Harding
underscore Las Vegas uh thank you all
man I love these guys they're like
family to us and uh hey we're gonna drop
another interview soon if you're
watching this you're at the end of the
interview though much love